[Music]
I'd like to tell you about two games of
chess the first happened in 1997 in
which Garry Kasparov a human lost a
deep-blue
a machine to many this was the dawn of a
new era one where man would be dominated
by machine but here we are 20 years on
and the greatest change in how we relate
to computers is the iPad not how the
second game was a freestyle chess
tournament in 2005 and which man and
machine could enter together as partners
rather than adversaries if they so chose
at first the results were predictable
even a supercomputer was beaten by a
grandmaster with a relatively weak
laptop the surprise came at the end who
won not a grandmaster with a
supercomputer but actually two American
amateurs using three relatively weak
laptops their ability to coach and
manipulate their computers to deeply
explore specific positions effectively
counteracted the superior chess
knowledge of the grandmasters in the
superior computational power of other
adversaries this is an astonishing
result average men average machines
beating the best man the best machine
and anyways isn't it supposed to be man
versus machine instead it's about
cooperation and the right type of
cooperation we've been paying a lot of
attention to Marvin Minsky's vision for
artificial intelligence over the last 50
years it's a sexy vision for sure many
of embraces become the dominant school
of thought on computer science but as we
enter the era of big data of network
systems of open platforms and embedded
technology I'd like to suggest it's time
to re-evaluate an alternative vision
that was actually developed around the
same time I'm talking about JCR
Licklider z-- human-computer symbiosis
perhaps better termed intelligence
augmentation I a wick lighter was a
computer science Titan who had a
profound effect on the development of
technology in the Internet his vision
was to enable man and machine to
cooperate in making decisions in
controlling complex situations without
the inflexible dependence on
predetermined programs note that word
cooperate
Lickliter encourages us not to take a
toaster and make it data from Star Trek
but to take a human and make her more
capable humans are so amazing how we
think our nonlinear approaches our
creativity iterative hypotheses all very
difficult if possible at all for
computers to do Lickliter intuitive we
realized this contemplating humans
setting the goals formulating the
hypotheses determining the criteria and
performing the evaluation of course in
other ways humans are so limited were
terrible at scale computation and volume
we require high-end talent management to
keep the rock band together and playing
Lickliter foresaw computers doing all
the routinize able work that was
required to prepare the way for insights
and decision-making silently without
much fanfare this approach has been
compiling victories beyond chess protein
folding a topic that shares the
incredible expansiveness of chess there
are more ways of folding a protein than
there are atoms in the universe this is
a world-changing problem with huge
implications for our ability to
understand and treat disease and for
this task supercomputer fueled brute
force simply isn't enough
Folie a game created by computer
scientists illustrates the value of the
approach non technical non biologist
amateurs play a video game in which they
visually arranged the structure of the
protein allowing the computer to manage
the atomic forces and interactions and
identify structural issues this approach
beats supercomputers 50% of the time and
tie 30% of the time fold it recently
made a notable and major scientific
discovery by deciphering the structure
of the Mason Fischer monkey virus a
protease that had eluded determination
for ever 10 years was solved by three
players in a matter of days perhaps the
first major scientific advance to come
from playing the video game last year on
the side of the twin towers the 9/11
memorial opened it displays the names of
the thousands of victims using a
beautiful concept called meaningful
adjacency places the names next to each
other based on the relationships to one
another friends families co-workers when
you put it all together it's quite a
computational challenge 3500 victims
1800 adjacency requests the importance
of the overall physical specifications
in the final aesthetics when first
reported by the media full credit for
such a feat was given to an algorithm
from the new york city design firm local
projects the truth is a bit more nuanced
while an algorithm was used to develop
the underlying framework humans use that
framework to design the final result so
in this case a computer I've evaluated
millions of possible layouts manage a
complex relational system and kept track
of a very large set of measurements and
variables allowing the humans to focus
on design and compositional choices so
the more you look around you the more
you see Licklider vision everywhere
whether it's augmented reality in your
iPhone or GPS in your car or
human-computer symbiosis is making us
more capable so if you want to improve
human-computer symbiosis what can you do
you can start by designing the human
into the process instead of thinking
about what a computer will do to solve
the problem design the solution around
what the human will do as well when you
do this you'll quickly realize that you
spend all of your time on the interface
between man and machine
specifically on designing away the
friction in the interaction in fact this
friction is more important than the
power of the man or the power of the
machine in determining overall
capability that's why two amateurs with
a few laptops handily beat a
supercomputer and a grandmaster what
Kasparov calls processes a byproduct of
friction the better the process the less
the friction and minimizing friction
turns out to be a decisive variable or
take another example Big Data every
interaction we have in the world is
recorded by an ever-growing array of
sensors your phone credit card computer
the result is big data and it actually
presents us with an opportunity to more
deeply understand the human condition
the major emphasis of most approaches to
Big Data focus on how do I store this
data how do I search this data how do i
process this data these are necessary
but insufficient questions the
imperative is not to figure out how to
compute but what to compute how do you
impose human intuition on data at this
scale again we start by designing the
human to the process when PayPal was
first starting as a business their
biggest challenge was not how do I send
money back and forth online it was how
do I do that without being defrauded by
organized crime why so challenging
because while computers can learn to
detect and identify fraud based on
patterns they can't learn to do that
based on patterns they've never seen
before an organized crime has a lot in
common with this audience brilliant
people relentlessly resourceful
entrepreneurial spirit and one huge
important difference purpose and so
while computers alone can catch all but
the cleverest fraudsters catching the
cleverest is the difference between
success and failure there's a whole
class of problems like this ones with
adaptive adversaries they rarely if ever
present with the repeatable pattern
that's discernable to computers instead
there's some inherent component of
innovation or disruption and
increasingly these problems are buried
in big data for example terrorism
terrorists are always adapting in minor
and major ways to new circumstances and
despite what you might see on TV these
adaptations and the detection of them
are fundamentally human computers don't
detect novel patterns or new behaviors
or humans do humans using technology
testing hypotheses
searching for insight by asking machines
to do things for them Osama bin Laden
was not caught by artificial
intelligence he was caught by dedicated
resourceful brilliant people in
partnerships with various technologies
as appealing as it might sound you
cannot algorithmically data mind your
way to the answer there is no find
terrorists button and the more data we
integrate from a vast variety of sources
across a wide variety of data formats
from very disparate systems the less
effective data mining can be instead
people will have to look at data and
search for insight and as Lickliter
foresaw long ago the key to great
results here is the right type of
cooperation and as Kasparov realized
that means minimizing friction at the
interface now this approach makes
possible things like combing through all
available data from very different
sources identifying key relationships
and putting of that in one place
something that's been nearly impossible
to do before the solemn this has
terrifying privacy and civil liberties
implications to others it foretells of
an era of greater privacy and civil
liberties protections but privacy and
civil liberties are of fundamental
importance that must be acknowledged and
they can't be swept aside even with the
best of intense so let's explore through
a couple examples the impact that
technologies built to drive
human-computer symbiosis have had in
recent time in October 2007 US and
coalition forces raided an al Qaeda safe
house in the city of Sinjar on the
Syrian border of Iraq they found a
treasure trove of documents 700
biographical sketches of foreign
fighters
these foreign fighters had left their
families in the Gulf the Levant in North
Africa
to join al-qaeda in Iraq these records
were human resource forms the foreign
fighters filled them out as they joined
the organization it turns out that
al-qaeda too is not without its
bureaucracy they answered questions like
who recruited you what's your hometown
what occupation do you seek and that
last question a surprising insight was
revealed the vast majority of foreign
fighters were seeking to become suicide
bombers for martyrdom hugely important
since between 2003 and 2007 Iraq had
thirteen hundred and eighty two suicide
bombings a major source of instability
analyzing this data was hard the
originals were sheets of paper in Arabic
that had to be scanned and translated
the friction in the process did not
allow for meaningful results in an
operational timeframe using humans PDFs
and tenacity alone the researchers had
to lever up their human minds with
technology to dive deeper to explore
non-obvious hypotheses and in fact
insights emerged 20% of the foreign
fighters were from Libya 50% of those
from a single town in Libya hugely
important since prior statistics but
that figure at 3% it also helped to hone
in on a figure of rising importance in
Al Quaida Abu Yahya al-libi a senior
cleric in the Libyan Islamic fighting
group in March of 2007 he gave a speech
after which there was a surge and
participation amongst Libyan foreign
fighters perhaps most clever of all
though and least obvious by flipping the
data on its head the researchers were
able to deeply explore the coordination
networks in Syria that were ultimately
responsible for receiving and
transporting the foreign fighters to the
border these were networks of
mercenaries not ideologues who were in
the coordination business for profit for
example they charged Saudi foreign
fighters substantially more than Libyans
money that would have otherwise gone to
al-qaeda
perhaps the adversary would disrupt
their own network if they knew they were
cheating would-be jihadists in January
2010 a devastating 7.0 earthquake struck
Haiti third deadliest earthquake of all
time left 1 million people 10% of the
population homeless one seemingly small
aspect of the overall relief ever became
increasingly important as the delivery
of food and water circuit rolling
January and February are the dry months
in Haiti yet many of the camps that
develop standing water the only
institution with detailed knowledge of
Haiti's flood plains had been leveled in
the earthquake leadership inside
so the question is which camps are at
risk how many people in these camps
what's the timeline for flooding and
give it very limited resources
infrastructure how do we prioritize the
relocation the data was incredibly
disparate US Army had detailed knowledge
for only a small section of the country
there was data online from a 2006
environmental risk conference others
geospatial data not have been integrated
the human goal here was to identify
camps for relocation based on priority
need the computer had to integrate a
vast amount of geospatial information
social media data and relief
organization information to answer this
question by implementing a superior
process what was otherwise a task for 40
people over three months became a simple
job for three people in 40 hours all
victories for human-computer symbiosis
were more than 50 years into Lickliter
his vision for the future and the data
suggest that we should be quite excited
about tackling this century's hardest
problems man and machine in cooperation
together thank you
[Applause]
[Music]